so gonna be a great lecture today it's
about proteins I love proteins don't
forget the handout yeah okay so I'm
going to briefly wrap up the lecture we
were doing on Friday because there were
a couple of things that I wanted to make
a note of and then we'll move on to
section 2.3 about amino acids peptides
and proteins now in the last class I
introduced you to the lipid ik molecules
and you can pick them out of a lineup
because they are rich in carbon carbon
and carbon hydrogen bonds as you can see
here in these line angle drawings the
majority of a lot of these molecules is
carbon carbon or carbon hydrogen they
are molecules that are mostly
hydrophobic so there are some
terminologies here what's hydrophobic
which can also be referred to as
lipophilic you either you can heat water
and love fatty acid or fatty types of
materials so there's both terms are
synonymous and some of the lipids are
what are known as an three Pathak and
they include hydrophilic and hydrophobic
components there are a couple of tiny
terms that I didn't mention explicitly
so I just want to go ahead and do that
now for example in this phospholipid
structure and we'll talk about these
they have long-chain fatty acids
attached via esters to this glycerol
unit so there's one here and the second
one here and then what's known as the
polar head group in those fatty acids
they could be fully saturated it means
they have no double bonds in the
structure so that term saturated is
equivalent to no double bonds so no
carbon-carbon double bonds or they could
be unsaturated where there is a double
bond within it so that's one or more
double bonds and those double bonds take
on a particular shape because there's
not freedom of rotation around double
bonds the same way there is around
single bonds so those single bonds you
can twist them around and twist them
around but the double bond geometry is
fixed and so double bonds we refer to
them as either trans where the two
groups are on opposite sides leaving the
double bond or we refer to them as sis
where the two groups are on the same
side and we tend to use that sis and
trans sort of naming system in a lot of
other contexts as well but you might
almost always want to remember the trans
is as far away as possible
sis is closer than trans alright so I'm
just gonna take you forward to the
phospholipid structure this is a very
important semipermeable membranes I made
up through the non covalent super
molecular Association of phospholipid
monomer units here's a monomer unit up
here you see it has an amphipathic
structure with a lot of hydrophobicity
but also hydrophilicity and these
molecules assemble into super molecular
structures that form the boundaries of
your cells saying they are semi
permeable tells us a little bit about
what can go through them if they were
fully permeable anything could come and
go and they wouldn't be much use frankly
it's like leaving the door open the
whole time but because they are semi
permeable only a few things can come and
go without extra help and other things
need active mechanisms to to go through
so let's take a look at the boundary
here so when you see a membrane bilayer
they are they're often shown looking
like this where every one of these units
is a phospholipid
and there's water on both sides of the
phospholipid because that polar head
group is interacting with water on both
sides so down here could be the inside
of the cell up here could be the outside
of the cell and a lot of cells
especially eukaryotic cells the ones
that make us up have a lot of endo
membranes membranes with
in the cells for example forming the
boundary to the nucleus or to the
mitochondria yes oh this guy must be so
this looks like it's probably a
saturated fatty acid so what do you
think this one might be folks
unsaturated and what's the double bond
geometry sis so yeah it is it's like a
it looks like a ballerina or something
okay so we're you have a lot of concerns
and we'll see later about how things get
in and out of cells but most commonly
things like oxygen or water and other
small hydrophobic molecules can pass
readily in and out through the semi
permeable barrier but other things
things that are charged things that are
big need a different mechanism to get in
and out and we will see later on how
proteins provide the opportunities to
Cargo things into cells or out of cells
even very large entities and there are
certain mechanisms whereby that happens
through a semi permeable membrane okay I
want to show you the other feature of
membranes they are self-healing what
this means is if you poke them you poke
a hole in a cellular membrane you
basically push apart those non-covalent
forces once you take the thing away be
it a needle or a very fine glass
capillary they seal right back up to
close to close the hole in the cell wall
so that kind of tells us that they're
non covalent forces so this is a really
cool video of someone doing micro
injection into eukaryotic cells the
needle points to the cell approaches the
surface you can drop something into the
cell and then the cell closes and
maintained regains its mackay its
integrity of the barrier so this is a
very cool
a nation people do this they have to not
drink too much coffee because it's quite
complicated to do a lot of
microinjection because you can really
cause carnage and your cell population
if you're if you're not very dexterous
with microinjection
but people have they can be very good at
it so I just want to ask a couple of
questions before you a couple of things
to think about before we close up the
lipids so here's a typical lipid bilayer
where I've highlighted a single lipid in
the colors those are the head groups and
all in white and gray are the
hydrophilic components and just one of
the phospholipids is highlighted and
that would be this molecular structure
here so first of all what do you think
the non covalent forces at that membrane
interface may be that is what's going on
here at the interface what are the types
of interactions that you might have
there give you a minute to think about
it and I want to show you that I'm
actually giving you a clue here because
you can see the structure negative
charge positive charge but also remember
this is a barrier to water so there are
other things going on with the solvent
that the membrane is sitting in because
there's water surrounding that barrier
layer anyone want to tell me what the
answer is and why yeah did you yeah yeah
between what and what
in
right so water so that what is a good
hydrogen bond donor and acceptor so
there will be hydrogen bonding
what about amongst all those lipid head
groups what's the other major force yeah
between the different charges so the
correct answer here is both of them
don't think it's just electrostatic it's
both it's electrostatic amongst the head
groups hydrogen bonding between all that
sort of dense bunch of charge and the
water and then the other question what
type of molecules can get across I've
already answered that question to you
salts are gonna need ways to get in and
out small proteins are too big to
dissolve in that membrane through
passive mechanisms so we're gonna have
to figure out how to get proteins in and
out of cells
neurotransmitters such as this this is
gaba or gamma amino butyric acid it's
charged it just can't get through
without a transporter of some kind and
it's actually proteins that end up doing
the heavy lifting of the transport
processes that we'll see okay so this
section will it be about the building
blocks of your protein macromolecules
which I want to remind you comprise 50%
of all of the macromolecules so that
suggests it's a pretty important class
of macromolecules that has a lot of
different functions
now the amino acid building lock blocks
look pretty simple they're called amino
acids because they have an amine the
carboxylic acid and there's a carbon
that is tetrahedral between the
carboxylic acid and the amine and the
simplest of those is when those are both
hydrogen but most of the amino acids are
differentiated from that this one I
showed you on the board this amino acid
is glycine usually when it's just a
lonely amino acid in aqueous solution
it's in a different charged form
just in consistent with what we talked
about in the last class so this is
glycine it's one of the 20 encoded amino
acids that means the amino acids that
are made through ribosomal biosynthesis
through a code that's provided by the
messenger RNA so they are encoded by
messenger RNA RNA and later on you'll
see all of the beautiful mechanics of
those processes now this table looks
pretty complicated so I'm going to
deconstruct it a bit but what I first of
all want to assure you is that these
twenty you will always get a handout
with these structures on them we are not
asking you to remember these structures
you might become familiar with some of
them but you do not have to remember
them you'll have a table that shows them
but on that table I won't necessarily
give you the information on what their
properties are because those are things
that you should be able to spot by
looking at their chemical structures all
right so that's important so these are
all line angle drawings so you see the
carbon the hydrogen's aren't shown in
there the charges are shown for what's
called the sidechain because most of the
amino acids
have a sigh change the amino acids are
also chiral but you'll learn more than
you ever wanted to know about chirality
in 512 so I won't weigh you down with
any of those properties so there is a
side chain that dictates the properties
of the amino acids one tiny detail the
amino acids that are encoded in our
proteins are all what are known as alpha
amino acids there are other amino acids
GABA that I showed you on the previous
slide is not an alpha amino acid
actually it's a gamma amino acid these
are called amino acids because the amine
group is at the Alpha position relative
to the carboxyl don't need to know a lot
more about that with respect to that so
let's take a look at this set of amino
acids and what you see is amino acid
side chains with rather different
properties I've amassed here's glycine
at the very top all amino acids have a
three-letter code or a one letter code I
particularly enjoy using one letter
codes and spelling out people's names in
peptides and things like that I'll let
you do that in privacy of your own room
it's kind of amusing to see if your name
actually spells out a peptide some some
of us get I get a little stuck with
Barbara because there are no B amino
acid 1 letters with a B the next most
abundant type of amino acid have
hydrophobic side chains what that means
is they have a lot of CHS are not a lot
else right so take a look at them
alanine has a methyl group for example
where I've shown they are that would be
Aladin and they get increasingly big
they're quite large some of them have
quite extended side chains are the ones
have side chains with rings with double
bonds in them those are what we would
designate in organic chemistry is
aromatic they show slit they're still
hydrophobic but they show different
properties to the to this other set of
amino acids some of these amino
may actually have hula groups in them
but their major feature is that they're
hydrophobic but in an amino acids such
as tyrosine you could not only have
hydrophobic interactions with that ring
system but also hydrogen bonding with
the O H on the tyrosine so some of the
amino acids can do a few different
things the next set of amino acids are
those that are polar and charged and
I've shown you the most common state of
all of those amino acids but you already
know that the amine of lysine is likely
to be charged this guanidinium group of
arginine take my word for it it's
charged it's a bit more complicated to
draw histidine is also one of those
that's annoying to draw but the
negatively charged side chains with a
carboxylate are both negatively charged
and that's something you would remember
from the previous class hopefully and
then finally their amino acids with
polar uncharged side chains such as
those shown here now this doesn't look
like a very exciting set of building
blocks how can life run on things made
of twenty relatively simple building
blocks with functional groups and it's
that the building blocks are not
functional themselves it is the polymers
that are made up of amino acids and I'll
always call them AAS because it's easier
for me the polymers of amino acids are
hetero polymers that means they're made
up of a bunch of different monomer units
when they're called hetero polymers and
the other important thing about these
polymers is that they are of defined
sequence what is the sequence it's the
order in which the amino acids appear so
I'm right and all the functions of
proteins are dictated by the order of
the amino acids let's take a look at the
side bar here so once again
remember a couple of things that we will
always give you this table to think
about come back there were a couple of
outliers I just want to mention quickly
so I've talked to you about luck glycine
the simplest amino acid with no
elaborate side chain prolene is a little
odd because it's side chain is kind of
in a cyclic structure and towards the
end of the class I'll talk to you about
collagen whose structure is totally
dependent on the involvement of prolene
in the sequence of the amino acids that
make up collagen and then the last sort
of unusual amino acid is cysteine it has
a file and the one clever thing about
cysteine I'm just gonna put a bit of a
peptide here one cysteine and then I'm
gonna put a second cysteine and these
are going to be deemed in a peptide ik
structure what cysteine can do is it can
exist either with the file sidechain SH
or it can be at a different oxidation
state where the two sulfur's are joined
to each other so for the most part your
linear arrangement of amino acids that
dictates this sequence is solely held by
it together by the Coulomb covalent
bonds in the peptide backbone that we'll
talk about in a minute but occasionally
in folded structures if two cysteines
are close to each other and the
environment is oxidizing they will form
a cross-linked but they're not what
drives folding they kind of fall into
place later on but that just sort of
sets cysteine apart a little bit for its
properties
all right okay so coming down the side
here amino acids are assembled in a
unique linear polymer of defined order
and we designate that defined sequence
the primary sequence
and proteins can be a thousand amino
acids fifteen hundred a hundred amino
acids they can be various lengths where
they you know we would generally
consider the smallest protein to be back
about four hundred amino acids and you
might go up to thousands of amino acids
I'm gonna write two thousand or more
here when the proteins are smaller they
are not capable of adopting too much
ordered structure and we mostly call
them peptides peptides are sort of
shorter sequences so peptide sequences
so this would be a protein and peptides
probably two to thirty nine amino acids
for these breakpoints are a little a
little bit more vague so the primary
sequence will define the structure of a
protein and we're gonna start to talk
about the hierarchical structure of
proteins that's put in place so and
that's the primary sequence and that
primary sequence is kind of a cool thing
because it's very specific it defines
it's got encoded into its structure the
three-dimensional fold of the protein
okay all the information for the folded
compact globular structure that's
functional is encoded in that primary
sequence it's a cryptic code we may may
not be able to tell by looking at it
what it really looks like but all the
information is there in order to program
the folding into a globular structure so
the primary sequence determines the fold
and it's the fold of the protein that
mandates its function it's not the
sequence of the protein the sequence
defines the fold the fold the
three-dimensional form defines the
function okay so that's very important
and I think it's absolutely amazing that
with a relatively limited set of
building blocks we can define so many
different functions of all the proteins
in our body that may be structural they
may be catalysts they may be things that
transfer information from the outside to
the inside of the cell all of that is
programmed with this rather limited set
of building blocks
okay now let's now talk about peptides
because one gets a little frustrated
looking at single amino acids they don't
tell us so much about the peptide ik
structure so I'm going to draw two amino
acids and then I'm going to tell you one
important thing so let's put our 1 and
I'm going to draw another amino acid and
I'm putting it in a particular
orientation or two because that
designates that these might be different
amino acids for example if our one is H
there's an implied hydrogen here that
would be glycine if our two is a methyl
group there's an implied hydrogen there
that would be alanine all right when
nature bonds all these amino acids
together it carries out a condensation
reaction to form a peptide bond between
these two components of the amino acid
the amine and the carboxylic acid now
I'm going to draw you the first of the
dipeptides that you'll meet there are so
many things to tell you about these
structures it sort of drives me crazy
thinking about oh I must remember to
tell them that oh I got to remember to
tell them that because the structures
are cool r1 okay so this is a dipeptide
two amino acids and there are some
characteristics I want you to remember
when we write out peptides we always
write them in 2c so in that peptide this
would be the carboxyl term
and this would be the amino terminus if
you don't always remember to write
things in this order and you tell your
friend oh go and get this peptide made
and you put it down in the wrong order
they'll make the wrong peptide so you
always there's basically an agreement
amongst everyone that we always write
from left to right the sequence of
peptides the next important thing about
this structure as you look at it there
are several bonds joining the polymeric
structure many of these bonds show free
rotations you can twist them around
there's nothing stopping that conversion
all of these show freedom of rotation so
the image or peptide bond is unique in
that there's restricted rotation about
that bond so it's as if you've got a
linear polymer but every third bond has
kind of stuck in a particular
orientation which starts to define a lot
of details about protein tertiary
structure it's not complete spaghetti
it's like spaghetti with little bits
that haven't been cooked they're stiffer
than the rest of the sequence and the
other really important thing about the
peptide structure is that embedded
within that structure there is the
amador peptide functional group where
remember this can be a hydrogen bond
acceptor and this can be a hydrogen bond
donor once you know that the next few
slides will make a lot of sense as we
talk about higher order structure of
proteins so let's just take a look at
that with a slightly longer peptide by
convention if I'm going to draw a
peptide that's methionine isoleucine
threonine you can look up that names on
those names on the chart that would be
the MIT peptide these are the three
amino acid
I'm going to condense them into a
tripeptide when I condense three amino
acids I spit out two molecules of water
and I put in place two Amador peptide
bonds if I go down this backbone every
third bond is going to be fixed fairly
fixed there's not freedom of rotation
around it and every third bond is going
to have the capacity to be involved in
hydrogen bonding interactions as I've
suggested here all right what else is
there here when when I write the MIT
peptide I write n first I second T third
if I wrote gim it would be a completely
different chemical structure with
different chemical properties so the
directionality is important to
understand and there you have it so now
you can go home and practice your name
in amino acids and draw them out if you
draw them out fairly sort of sharply
then you'll never get confused about
what ends what and what where the
substituents are but it's important to
remember as you're making a dipeptide i
forget this doesn't work as you're
condensing a dipeptide
when you're putting these R groups on
one goes up one goes down but these are
nuances of the structure that may may be
lit for a good for a later discussion so
here is now a longer linear peptide and
the suggestion of a globular structure
that might be found if that peptide was
folded up so and the primary sequence
here defines the globular structure and
the process whereby you go from the
extended primary sequence to the folded
structure is called protein folding
and physical chemists and physicists and
computational chemists have for years
try to understand how we could predict
the folded structure from the primary
sequence it's not simple because what
you're doing is you're solving a massive
energy diagram where as you fold a
structure up you're trying to maximize
all those covet non-covalent forces for
maximum maximum thermodynamic stability
right it's kind of a three dimensional
puzzle where you're trying to have as
many hydrogen bonds electrostatic
interactions and so on as you can
possibly make
so when computational chemists try to
fold proteins they're basically solving
a three-dimensional puzzle where they
are maximizing interactions and there
are a lot of initio immaculate I nameks
programs that are now starting to be
able to fold proteins into fairly
reliable structures but they don't
always get them right because they they
haven't gotten all the clues yet and
also while they may be able to do ab
initio or computational folding with
small structures the headache gets way
bigger the larger the structures gets so
the the predictors aren't very good at
predicting big structures they're
getting better or predicting small
structures and so just to reinforce to
you the primary sequence is established
by covalent bonds the peptide bonds but
the globular tertiary structure is based
on non covalent covalent interactions
okay now I want to ask you this I love
cartoons with science in them but you
know 1020 percent of the time they get
they make mistakes and I thought this
one was particularly pertinent it's a
bunch of guys lugging around in a lab
and says well we finished the genome app
now we've just have to figure out how to
fold it what is wrong with that cartoon
what fault yeah
yeah yeah the genome doesn't fold his
double helical duplex DNA or something
you're actually folding proteins so the
cartoon is not quite right but it's sort
of kind of cute all right now when we
talk about the non covalent forces that
hold proteins together I just want you
to remember from last time this set of
non covalent forces because if you
understand them and recognize them
you'll understand how they may occur in
folded protein structures all right so
here's a peptide sequence here's a
puzzle for you you can go back and
figure out what the one letter code
spells there just take out your um your
table with all the amino acids it's a
pendent to the back of your p-set and
you'll be able to see what that very
large peptide spells all right and then
when you're working that out while
you're here you got to listen to me for
the time being okay so the first order
we get it there's a primary sequence the
next thing to think about is what's
known as secondary structure it's higher
order than just the primary sequence and
it's established by non covalent bonds
and it's called secondary my writings
horrid today secondary structure and
those are interactions that are put in
place exclusively by interactions
between the peptide bonds of what's
known as the peptide backbone so if we
look at this structure these are the
side chains the peptide backbone is this
continuous linear sequence that's what
we would call the peptide backbone and
the secondary structure is put in place
by hydrogen bonding between components
of the peptide backbone so for example
hydrogen bonds such as that
or a different hydrogen bonding
interaction such as that between the
atoms that have lone pairs of electrons
and the other atoms had heavy atoms that
hold a hydrogen that's quite acidic and
there are a couple of major forms of
secondary structure what I'm showing you
here is what's known as the alpha helix
first deduced by Pauling in fact through
model building he said proteins could
form these ordered structures and an
alpha helix is an ordered structure
exclusively made up from the hydrogen
bonding interactions of the peptide
backbone and you can look at this
helical structure it's a continuous
strand of peptide but there are hydrogen
bonds between cos and NH s all the way
through the backbone such that this
strand of polypeptide can fold up into a
cylindrical helical structure where all
those are groups side chains of the
amino acids on the perimeter of that
helix so this secondary structure is an
important one because it's very
prevalent in a lot of proteins the next
secondary structure is also held
together by hydrogen bonding and it's
interactions between stretched out
strands of polypeptides that may not be
close to each other in the primary
sequence but they align in in the folded
structure and so for example what I've
shown you here is what's known as this
sir this guy is enter C this is an anti
parallel beta sheet and across that
sheet there are continuous opportunities
for hydrogen bonding interaction if the
strands run in opposite directions its
anti parallel if they're in the same
direction is parallel these two
secondary structure elements make up a
lot of the sort of basics of how
proteins start to fold their key non
covalent forces and they're also other
smaller motifs one is called a beta turn
where the the peptide sequence may go
through a chain reversal so the sequence
would look like this I'm gonna just
throw it and I'll talk to you in a
moment about ribbon diagrams and this
piece here would be the turn whereas
that would be the interactions enforced
by the sheep these are the ordered
elements of secondary structure you
don't have to be able to figure them out
but you have to be able to pick them out
in order to understand the structure
okay so even those simple elements still
it's hard to make big enough structures
to have functions so as I mentioned in a
continuation of the theme the protein
folding is hierarchical you can start to
put together elements of secondary
structure to make things that are a
little larger helix turn helix helix
with a different kind of turn may be put
in place by a metal iron or something or
a strand turn strand or now something
that's a composite of these two major
types of cell secondary structure the
helix and the turn and these really
start to be proteins that might be big
enough to be able to do something but
they're all exclusively held together by
non-covalent forces between the amides
or peptide bonds in the backbone of the
protein okay not very exciting just yet
now one other little clue that people
will you might see and you might be
confused people sometimes when they're
drawing sort of a quick picture of a
protein they might draw a helix but
instead of really showing it in detail
they might show it as a cylinder so you
might need to pick that out of a
structure and then I want to call your
attention to the fact that in all those
motifs when you join one helix to
another you might need a turn a strand
to another strand you need a turn and so
on okay so this is like taking your very
extended sort of polymer knowing there
are different kinks in it because of the
back bow bonds but folding it up in a
structure that
maximizing the opportunity for another
order of structure which we'll talk
about now all right so we've seen
primary/secondary is just with backbone
and things start to get much more
interesting when we get to tertiary
structure because tertiary structure is
enabled by all these other interactions
electrostatic hydrogen bonding
hydrophobic forces that can be put in
place due to the side chains of the
amino acids interacting with each other
or with the backbone structure so I'm
going to walk you through this so you
can sort of get a sense of how these
three dimensional puzzles work on a very
small scale so look here that's a very
small motif and what I'm going to call
your attention to is when you fold up
these motifs when the secondary
structure is in place a lot of the side
chains are near each other and they can
engage in long distance contacts and so
for example I'm going to show you
interactions between side chains between
side chains and the peptide backbone or
side chains and water but what I want
you do is take a look at this and see
can you can you put any of those
potential interactions on the drawing
that's on your handout it's pretty
obvious where there's a an electrostatic
interaction right okay between plus get
those out the way those are the easy
ones and then interactions between
hydrophobic groups where they want to
amass that lipophilic structures so it's
not exposed as much to water so they
cluster so those are easy and then you
can start thinking about what are all
the hydrogen bonds you could draw here
I've shown one between side chains
between side chains and backbone between
side chains and water and those may all
contribute to the ultimate thermodynamic
stability make sure you get your
hydrogen bonds right remember two donors
don't interact with a it's with each
other and two acceptors don't so this
might describe the folding possibilities
of that small
Lutie now what I want to show you is an
ab initio simulation of a folding
process so let me just get that a little
bigger on the screen so this is
computing gb1 is a very small protein
that folds reversibly under appropriate
conditions and what I'm going to do is
forward you through this video this is a
simulation this is all computation it's
not looking at anything by spectroscopy
or in solution or anything like that and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna forward
you through the structure this is multi
scale modeling it's got its got a lot of
details in how it's done but the
starting point is a very denatured
protein all stretched out right and what
I'm gonna do is just show you for a few
seconds you know this thing's like
trying to find its thermodynamic minimum
and it's actually failing pretty badly
and it it does that for about 3060
seconds of the simulation so I made a
point to myself to take you to about
minute 1 where things start to get
fairly interesting you're saying well
what's interesting about that you see
that nascent helix in the background and
the red and the blue is starting to form
strands that are a little bit aligned
and it's trying to find as many
connections as possible to satisfy a
stable structure at a certain point in
the simulation five of the hydrophobic
groups are in a little team they're in a
little hydrophobic cluster and that's a
breakpoint in the folding process
because that gets everything glued
together better so that the rest of it
now can start to really find its final
place in the folded structure these
early structures are known as molten
globules a lot of the interactions are
not yet in place but the hydrophobic
cluster is critical but then after that
it's almost as if you're sliding
downhill to get all the remaining
interactions in place to fold the
protein ok so protein folding is a
puzzle
that can be solved computationally by
maximizing thermodynamic interactions so
it's Sigma this some of this some of
this some of that that's gonna get
difficult the larger the protein gets
but for small proteins those simulations
really start to make sense okay all
right so let's just move on here last
good what did you think of the
simulation it's kind of cool right so
you can find the link in the sidebar so
just pop these back on now and that's
the folded structure all right so with
many proteins they're much more complex
than that so for example here's cyclin a
it's involved in cell cycle and you can
see it's alpha helical structure
dominantly very clearly all those
beautiful alpha helixes next to it is
the green fluorescent protein which is a
cylindrical structure made up of a C
parallel beta sheets what's really cool
is when you sort of rotated you can see
all those sheets but then it does this
little sort of curtsy to the audience
and you can look down into the barrel
and then in some cases proteins may be a
mixture of secondary structure elements
here's a little hard to tell this is
triose phosphate isomerase but if you
look down it you can see the Gila C's
and there's also a group of beta strands
that are held together so in that
protein it's a mixture of alpha helix
and beta sheet now I'm not going to tell
you much about pulling up protein
databank files right now because I want
to cover the next topic and then when we
have a few minutes later on I'll show
you but wherever I show you a structure
I'm trying to show you the protein data
bank code and in the website you can see
there is a free download of Pi mall
which is the program I used to create
all these structures and movies so you
can really look at things and believe me
it took me about three years to learn
how to use it probably take you about a
week or maybe a couple of days so if I
can learn it you can certainly learn it
now there is one final element of
protein structure the people get kind of
hung up on and it's what's called put
ternary structure it's like aren't we
done yet so in addition to all of these
let's say I have a folded motif and
there's its structure that would be have
primary secondary between the strands or
the helix and tertiary structure right
but in some cases proteins pulled up to
quaternary structure where it's multiple
of these units joined together I could
have picked a simpler fold but doesn't
get you the general gist of it all right
where these are actually associated by
non covalent forces so there's more than
one polypeptide chain in fact here would
be four polypeptide chains coming
together in a higher order structure
that's made up of four of those units
the prototypic example of this is the
protein that carries oxygen around in
your blood which is hemoglobin and it
has four primary sequences that have
come together in a tetrameric quaternary
structure hemoglobin is kind of
interesting because it's made up of two
alpha and two beta subunits if all these
subunits were identical they would be
called homo oligomers all the same
pieces if they are different they are
called hetero oligomers we'll see a
little bit more about this when i talk
about hemoglobin in the next class
because the the features of the
quaternary structure are very very
important for the proper transport of
oxygen and single mutations can really
mess things up and you'll you'll see
more about that in the in the next class
so just to wrap that little bit up
proteins are condensation polymers of
amino acids each protein sequence is
defined by covalent bonding native
proteins most of them that are not don't
have quaternary structure of
through secondary and tertiary
interactions these things that we
already talked about and foldings
defined by how to maximize all those
non-covalent forces to get the maximum
thermodynamic stability with the maximum
number of interactions and subunits may
also come together through quaternary
structure okay so I'm going to talk to
you about several proteins throughout
the course but for now I want to focus
you in on a structural protein that
provides mechanical support for tissues
in the next class we'll talk about
transporters and enzymes and as we move
on to signaling things like receptors
and membrane proteins and so on so the
protein I'm gonna describe to you is
collagen it is the most abundant protein
in the human body
it plays enormous roles it's not an
enzyme it's not a catalyst it's not a
transporter it is one of those
structural proteins where the structure
of collagen has evolved to provide a
mechanical stability to lot of essential
components of complex organisms and
there are many different types of
collagen that are found in different
parts of the body for example bone
tendon cartilage and so on they are all
collagen structures but they have subtle
differences maybe some have different
slightly different mechanical properties
to adapt the functions that they perform
okay a signal and what I'm going to show
you is that a single amino acid change
in the primary sequence of collagen can
destabilize the structure so it is no
longer viable and no disease type I'm
going to talk to you about is a doozy a
set of diseases known as collagen AAPA
thiis and the particular one is called
osteogenesis imperfecta osteo always
refers to bone because collagen plays a
critical role in the structure of bone
bone isn't just bone it's collagen
involved in it and it's also this
disease is called brittle bone syndrome
and here's the x-ray of a baby born with
brittle bone syndrome and you'll see
that the long bones in the upper arm are
all irregular because the bones are
brittle and they'll they'll break even
in utero
a lot of babies with this defect can't
even be born through the birth canal
because it would crush the bones and
many of them don't survive very long at
all
some survive with different kinds of
cases but their lives are greatly
impacted and they could just sort of hit
a table and the bones would break all
right there are other sort of serious
situations where parents are actually
accused of abuse to the child but the
child actually had brittle bone syndrome
and it was just through you know helping
them put their clothes on or taking them
upstairs the bones got broken very
readily
so osteogenesis imperfecta really
describes a collection of these defects
now the collagen tertiary structure is
shown here it's actually made up of a
type of helix it's not an alpha helix
it's a poly prolene helix where the
individual subunits in that tersh in the
structure are fairly long and extended
and I show you three strands in this
polymeric structure yellow a red and a
green
and these roll together into a three
helix bundle that has a fibrillar
structure and then all these structures
come together to make the macromolecular
structure that is collagen it's not just
one of those peoples it's bundles of
those fibrillar very organized pattern
where you could even see that patterning
in an electron microscopy and there are
many genetic defects of collagen and
what's so important to think about this
if you have a defect in one strand that
defect will propagate through every
single strand if this is one strand made
up of three polypeptide chains it
propagates all the way through the
structure and I believe I have a little
time to just show you here's the
collagen structure I'm just showing you
how its extended those are three
independent strands and there's a set of
magenta residues in the middle which
come from a defect
in the sequence where a glycine has been
changed to an alanine and that so I'm
gonna show you this movie because it
shows you right at the center of the
structure there are residues painted in
pink and what I'm going to do is show
you close-up of that segment if you look
at those HeLa sees they're all nicely
organized except where that defect is
and that defect is caused by the change
of a hydrogen to a methyl group on three
residues that come together and that
bulges out that fibrillar structure and
makes it not as compact and beautiful as
it should be
in the version that's got the glycine
there so if you look at it you can even
see that helix gets bulged out and is
not as well aligned as the rest of the
structure and then that defect gets
propagated into all the fibrin results
in the weakening of the bones either the
collagen fails to form properly or the
collagen when it forms it has much less
mechanical stability so I think that's a
good place to stop and now pick up next
time with hemoglobin oh one last little
thing a couple of things for you to do
there's a great link on the website to
the protein databank to see how enzymes
work and if you have a little time it
would be awesome if you could just take
a quick flick through those parts of the
text these slides are posted with these
are reading assignments and they're
posted in color if you want to look at
them again
you